okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel and
welcome to the audacity
so
today i have two special guests on the
channel um they come out in full force
fighting feminism with me we got ali
yes the audacity of this [ __ ]
and rebecca
what up
so if you guys don't know they have two
fire ass channels i
have been watching them
for a minute okay if you like my stuff
you will love their stuff because we all
hate feminism
100
but what is there to love they're like
the meanest people on the planet like i
don't know we're feminists or blue
filled men they're equally angry no
they're so inclusive
except they forget to invite us to the
parties
yeah macy gray you know she uh she
wussed out on that one she should have
stood her ground
i'm so mad about that macy gray
you didn't hear about this oh my gosh no
let's let's hear the audacity i'm ready
right okay so rebecca go ahead
okay so macy gray is a singer i don't
know if you know that
this is like i'm like i'm older than you
guys so she was around when i was around
all right so macy gray uh i think went
on pierce morgan and said that
women are women and trans women are
essentially not biological women so
and then she went on the
was it the view not the view um she went
on the good morning today show or
something like that
and then said that she
learned from all of her mistakes
and she's now says that whoever
identifies as a woman is a woman
it was it was also like the worst
apology ever like i feel like that was
very messy gray of her to be like look i
probably don't want to say this but they
made me say this let me just say this
yeah
that was the pr team definitely that was
like
um
you
you messed up girl isn't it nice
building your platform on whatever the
hell you want to talk about so no one
can cancel you
try
it's really good
so guys if you don't know this segment
is where we talk about all the people
that have the audacity this week this
can include personal stories sometimes
or people in the media
so guys
this week we're going to talk about
who had the audacity so sure
so um
this week we had a lovely woman um
running for senator
oh no she is a senator oh my god so
democrats
convenient of course always the
democrats
rhode island state senator tierra mack
ripped for video of herself twerking
a rhode island state senator is getting
ridiculed for posting a campaign video
of her twerking upside down a barely
there bikini
democrat here tierra mack 28 used her
official district tick tock page on the
4th of july to post the saucy clip of
her shaking her booty while in a
handstand on a beach that ass
that ass
that ass someone can be heard yelling
admiringly before mac wearing a skimpy
yellow bikini turns the camera and begs
vote senator mack the state senator
advertised the clip as a promised
senator thirst trap at block island
it was just one
she posted in the revealing outfit
during her beach trip another asking how
many nip slips she was allowed oh there
was more so this is a
nice clip we got
um okay
you already have three one of her teased
max who described her as a black queer
woman
max tweet twerk
max twerk quickly racked up more than
seventy thousand views with one admirer
saying admirer saying i need to see some
more politicians doing this
tempted to move to rhode island just to
say this is my senator another fan wrote
as others sealed their support look at
her looking all happy
naysayers however quickly ripped her for
needing to reply on a tacky stunt to get
votes if this is what's running for our
country we are in serious trouble when
commenter wrote well another said if her
opponent doesn't use this video then do
they want to win
another accused of her of having set the
race back years with this well another
told her i don't ever want to hear you
complain about how women aren't
respected in this country after posting
this
tucker carl
tucker carlson was among those poking
fun at mac's performance playing the
clip on fox news saying that
sarcastically that her demonstrated
talent proved she was the next rising
star in the democratic party
so guys um
we're gonna stop my screen share
and just get your get your takes what do
you guys think
i want to see laurie lightfoot next
[Laughter]
no please no it was laurie lightfoot oh
my gosh
she's the worst she's the mayor she's
the governor the mayor of
chicago the mayor of
chicago okay she looks like beetlejuice
oh i mean i should know this i do i'm
from chicago i know this lady i've seen
her face i didn't know her she's
beetlejuice don't say it
is she
she
maybe i don't know remember she had the
halloween costume and she did she looked
like the thickest superhero like she
looked like she got the vid but okay
anyhow those are that's what i think
i want to see lori lightfoot next since
like that's what we're doing we're
twerking for votes it's not enough
it's not enough to do the mailing stuff
but you know i'll be less controversial
on this channel
um
we hate women sorry keep going keep
going no but honestly i think it's funny
that
the whole female empowerment thing
really rides on twerking and
you know showing your tits off like
that's really how you get the point
across
so you know kudos to her i guess like
she's getting the attention that she
wants and that's literally why she
posted on the tick tock like why would
you post on your political page and if
you're a senator why would you even post
twerking in the first place like
you're a senator who's going to take you
seriously now they all seen your
ass
like shaking
video
you know what though i wouldn't be upset
if aoc did it though like i'm okay with
that no aoc needs to shut up and never
speak again okay i'm so sorry
i do not like her it's videos like this
that make me want to return our right to
vote
i don't people be like oh like you
wanted equal rights because i did this
video where i said that you know women
shouldn't be in combat and all these
guys are angry they're like no you
wanted this i'm like i didn't ask for
none of that
driving i don't even think i should have
a driver's license like no offense it's
just like not my forte that's like the
right to vote i'd give it up because
women trend toward communism like they
vote with fifi's like no thank you no
thanks especially like how many dumb
women are gonna be like you know what
i'm gonna vote for this lady she's
twerking on tick tock like that's
y'all
come on i'll take one for the team i'll
seriously i'll take one for the team
i'll take away our right to vote
to get the outcomes i want you know what
i mean
you're going to go down for that you're
literally going to go down i've said it
so many times
so i've said it look at it
i'm gonna i'm gonna take one for the
team how they voted for somebody with
dementia you know what i'm saying like
what
like let me vote for somebody that won't
give me the the
what is it the the baby formula like you
know we're just not doing that good with
these decisions like i don't know
i mean we're back like let's let our
husbands vote for us
i'm tired with that
james is like solid guy
yeah yeah james james and i very much
agree on all things in the political
landscape
he's probably more conservative or he's
probably more
of a stickler than i am i kind of laugh
this stuff off he's like
it's it's
i'll let him vote for me for sure
should we start a movement return our
rights
uh yeah i mean i'm shooting i'm down
like i have all my girlfriend like many
of my girlfriends are coming out and
they're saying look like we just don't
seem to be voting well okay like no
offense it's not a forte we'd be voting
based off of feelings but you know what
i found was interesting too
is it's a it's this new thing where
women are like oh yeah i'm queer and
it's like because that wasn't the tick
tock like i'm a black queer woman but
one time i went to the gym and these
other you know college fit white women
you know i'm in the midwest so they were
talking about like oh yeah like i'm
queer i'm like look making out with your
girlfriend at the bar when you're drunk
doesn't necessarily make you queer you
know what i mean like i don't what is
this like i'm a woman also i'm queer
like why do you want to be included in
everything and that's women
yeah because no one because women don't
want to
feel like they're out of the party like
they want to be a part of everything and
um that was like a trend in college so
like if you made out remember katy perry
i kissed a girl and i like it like we
we've been there done that so like can
we just keep it pushing like why are we
still why are we trying to be queer
everyone like i don't understand next
you know it's like uh what's her name
what's that singer demi lovato who like
became non-binary overnight and she can
talk to aliens and like stuff like that
she was a beautiful woman
a beautiful woman
and then she went like non-binary queer
trans whatever like
and then just became weird like
literally the weirdest person
and speaks to it or sings to aliens so
i don't know
did we bring back exclusion bring back
exclusion not everybody gets invited to
the party not everybody
well some of you were never not invited
to a party in high school and it shows
that's character building that's
character building
when they come up on monday and they say
wow that [ __ ] was lit and you say what
party
character building
bring back exclusion
uh yes this is why i love pearl did you
know about all that stuff that happened
to demi lovato have you been watching
no i mean every time i every time i talk
to her she's like crazier and crazier
well not talk to her like hear about her
i was gonna say you talked to her one on
one like pearls no no no
i sometimes i feel like i know these
people
right well her she od'd and she had a
stroke so i think that she just like
honestly took brain damage because like
after that she's coming up with all
types of things like for real for real
pearl like blair white has reviewed her
clips and she really was like singing to
aliens and then she was like talking to
a ghost i think or an alien she's like i
have experienced trauma too i'm like but
like in this dimension though like this
one this was the dimension
and over a certain age
i just feel like you can't blame your
trauma anymore
like it's just
i don't know what age that is but it's
just like at some point you got to be
like you know what i think i just make
bad decisions
that's too hard for women to to get to
that point i was literally thinking
about that today it's like we've
we've gone to a point in society where
you can't even talk to a woman about
anything that she disagrees with or
she'll go crazy like she'll lose her
ever-loving mind and then
literally
like hit you with all of these attacks
whatever she'll send her friends to you
too
and it's ridiculous like they act like
little children like throwing a
full-blown tantrum
at the mall and all you want to do is
slap him in the face like i'm so sorry
to break it to you you can't
you cannot
put your trauma on anyone else
sorry
can't do it
do you did you guys hear about that one
time demi lovato tried to cancel an ice
cream shop because yes we had an eating
disorder and then she went in there and
i guess they had like gluten-free and
dairy-free ice cream and she flipped her
ish and posted it on twitter tried to
dox these people apologize the next day
like i'm sorry my bad you know i i'm
done i'm done with the light the
audacity
the audacity of the stages
okay
so the next story we're gonna share
okay
another the audacity
so
there's two parts to this
but share system ally i'm so glad you
shot taught me how to share my screen
audio
yes any time so so this is a reaction
from chi shazam because i couldn't
oh my god
the name is right there okay well
i thought i could i thought i couldn't
find the tick tock
but it's right there anyways it's on the
right so
oh wait i don't know i did part two we
gotta do part one first
so this is a woman who thought it'd be a
good idea
to sleep with her daughter's baby daddy
now i don't
i don't know what world these women live
in where like you're competing with your
mom for guys
i never had this
we're just gonna watch the video wasting
time
let's get it this is what you do with my
mom are you serious i know you're lying
and you just sitting there quiet you
ain't got to say mom
really you ain't got to say so you just
no i don't want to hear that yeah i'ma
put it on facebook i want everybody to
see the two
i don't care who you are obviously you
don't care that i'm your daughter right
you over here sleeping with my baby
daddy that's my baby daddy
taxi
you
because he draws his mind
the camera is all in your face take my
off because i paid for it
give me this shirt i bought
listen i don't know what's worse about
this situation i ain't going nowhere
like the audacity what are you
that is so cringe to watch literally
i can't hold my expressions in like it's
so bad
imagine imagine your mother in bed with
your boyfriend or baby daddy whoever
right and she's giving you advice while
she's laying up right next to him and
he's just lounging did you not see him
he was so comfortable he was way too
comfortable with that and then she goes
on to say that they weren't doing
anything
that did not look like it was not
anything
like
come on
i can't even imagine looking at my mom
and then she's giving every like she's
giving her
relationship advice that's the audacity
right there
go ahead allie what are your thoughts
my thoughts is uh
like it's possible this was a skit
supposedly it could have been however
nonetheless these things do happen in
the hood and it's like some really
really ghetto stuff like i wouldn't i'm
never going back to the hood i've
disavowed it it's stupid like women are
out here really doing this stuff i think
i think growing up i heard a story one
time where a lady left her man for her
stepson and i was like y'all like this
is this is the plot of
a prawn video like what
so yeah the audacity of these ghetto a
mugs i'm done
oh my god the first
go ahead sorry go ahead i just want to
say the fact that this would be a skit
in the first place is just like um i did
a reaction of the lady who basically was
pissed off that her boyfriend or husband
bought her a brand new audi
and
like everyone was saying that that was
also a skit why why are these things
skits why are people recording this like
this is what i don't understand if it is
fake
why
for attention that person looks like it
like they all look like idiots there
right and it just i don't know it makes
no sense why would you make a skip like
skit like that to get attention like
you could do anything else with your
life
anything else
and you know what i don't you know
what's crazy to me i can't imagine like
a world that i would live in where my
mom is posting ass pictures on instagram
or trying to sleep with guys that i'm
trying to sleep with you know or like
competing with me like this is why women
can't be by themselves
okay like this is why we're supposed to
get married
because
we just be trifling you know what i mean
like this is why
this is why i'm trying to find a man
because i don't want to do that
i can't be like that at 50. oh no no
it's true it's true i make the worst
decisions by myself but for me mostly
it's like i'm too nice i'm like this
person isn't going to rob me here's 500
my husband's like are you stupid or are
you dumb like which one is it i'm like
you know what snacks facts i don't even
know why i asked like
[Laughter]
guys it's bad it's a weird world out
there like really weird world that we're
living in and and the worst part about
it is that like before maybe in like you
know like 20 years ago
before the internet was a thing before
tick tock and before like these things
happened right but it wasn't all up in
our face like we have to
literally deal with all of this crap in
our face constantly
and i think that's the worst part is you
know
just confronting
the craziness every single day i wake up
and my phone is like blaring people like
people screaming out of my phone and i'm
like this is the world that we live in
just pure insanity and that's what gets
propelled
in the forefront of social media and the
regular media they want everyone to be
crazy
well i mean that's how i felt when roe v
wade happened and i kept saying all a
bunch of people's thoughts online so i
went to my local college campus because
i was like are people really bugging but
when i went to campus i went on
this app called yik yak it's like an
anonymous thing where you can post your
thoughts and it's like whisper
and you know there were some crazy women
up in there talking about like i have to
get an iud they're going to outlaw birth
control like
just turn off the handmaid's tale but i
also think social media really shows us
how people feel because i used to be in
college and i would be like you know no
like i kind of think leftists hate me
like i kind of think they hate me and
all my professors would tell me oh like
you know it's it's magnified i'm like i
don't know because i'm friends with my
friends in real life on facebook they
say they hate people that voted for
donny so like you sure
sure these people like me like i don't i
don't think so so i think social media
magnifies things true but i also think
it like allows people to share their
i don't know crappy beliefs just like
the worst things that you could think
they're like oh let me type this out
there let me add my my scum to society
yeah um i think pearl you were talking
about this how
if you are an influencer
influencer or like a creator you almost
feel like it's even magnified more
because you're constantly
in this state of
like fight or flight like you're
constantly fighting you're constantly in
disagreement because that's what drives
numbers that's what drives attention
like people don't care that we're
talking about um how to be a better
woman how to be more feminine how to
create healthy happy marriages they want
to see us like [ __ ] talk other people on
the internet like that's really and it's
not i mean like we're doing it like i
will give it to the people but like
but that's what they want to see they
want to see drama they want to see all
of this the the filth come up
from the internet and that's why these
videos take off and then get you know
thrown up on every other social media
platform because
it's like
let's amplify the delusion let's amplify
the
the confusion everything like
the the
crappiest part of society let's put it
on the forefront and make it make
everyone think that this is normal
like normalized dysfunction
well and that's
like they're trying to normalize bad
decisions like i don't know why it's
controversial when i say
you shouldn't raise kids in single
parent households
pearl don't
well get me started
like why this is this we went viral like
this is viral clips off of our sauce
cast interview no like straight up i
would rather go to afghanistan than to
redo my childhood in a single mother
home and that like i 100
like i am not kidding i'd rather do that
like it was ridiculous and then these
progressive policies be patent people on
the back give them excuses left right
and center i'm like okay and then we
wonder we wonder why these crazy things
happen where we have like these
shiftless young men that are taking
their anger out on society i'm like i'm
not surprised i'm not surprised
all these social scientists are they're
wrong y'all should watch aaron clary
sometime like his whole thing is just
just dunking on america it's such a good
channel
okay
i am going to share to you guys
part two of this video
so you know some people
when they do the bad thing right
they'll own up to it and be like yeah
my bad you know
i mean you have video evidence of me
doing what i'm not supposed to do so at
this point
you would think right that you just own
up to it because
i mean
anyways but some people
that is not the case so let's let's
[Music]
but
i'm really getting tired okay guys i
didn't want to have to do this
but
i'm really getting tired of people
labeling me
telling me i'm an unfit mom
that i shouldn't have been in the bed
with my daughter's baby daddy
um
that i slept with him i'm really getting
tired of you know people in my inbox
facebook instagram tick tock under my
videos saying nasty mean things
when you guys really don't know the full
story
so
like i said i didn't want to have to do
this but i think it's about time you
guys hear my side of the story
was it me and the video yes
my hair is the same
my nails is the same color look at those
nails
[Music]
problem number one right there man okay
clear
did i sleep with my daughter's baby
daddy no
what you guys need to understand
is that
that night
my daughter did go to work
i was tending to my granddaughter
and what you guys do not understand is
my granddaughter will not go to sleep
unless she's in her mother's bed
so
i lay down with my
granddaughter once she went to sleep
i picked her up
and i put her in her room and put her in
the bed
and sometime
during that time
when i was you know putting her in the
bed
i'm assuming that's when
the baby daddy came in the room
and got in the bed
when i went back in the room
um
i laid down because i was tired it's a
pretty big bed
i didn't really
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait death
oh it goes back okay hold on
next to me it's pretty dark and
everything
and
i
felt the arm
around me
and so i got up
in shock
and i'm like what the hell are you doing
and he was like well i thought
you was
my girl
and i'm like
no
uh what are you doing in here
um and he's like well
you know um
i'm sorry i didn't know it was you
you know miss sharon
you know i've been meaning to talk to
you
and i'm like well
um
can it wait like um
is it really that
so i'm like fine if you really need to
talk i need you to
get up and put on some clothes
and then we can talk about it i can't
stand those nails as i was
oh sorry guys i don't have premium
yeah we gotta wait
[Music]
yeah my premium kinda yeah yeah
hold on hold on
[Music]
oh six more seconds hold up
all right now we're back in the process
of telling him this
that's when my daughter
came in the room
um
i'm assuming she must have heard us
talking or whatever
she walks in she sees it or she heard
him busting those cheeks
fast
not slow like my coffee like i like my
women in the bed
of course she's thinking the words like
you guys are sleeping together like mom
how dare you do me like this how could
you you know um
and
of course she's in a fit of rage i mean
she had every right uh were we wrong for
being in the bed together
yes okay sorry i'll keep going yes
but you guys need to understand that i
let him know that he needed to get up
and he needed to
put on some clothes if he wanted to talk
to me because i felt it was
inappropriate
so
timing is everything and unfortunately
my daughter walked in on on us
and
spazzed the [ __ ] out which she had every
right to so
um
[Music]
me and my daughter are not talking
uh we haven't talked since this whole
incident um
i haven't been there um
i just want to be able to
like i said um
you know
have my daughter
understand what really happened she
hasn't even given me a chance to even
explain anything
good she just shut down and she wants
nothing to do with me
or him so
um
i don't know what else to do guys um
maybe you know if someone's listening
contact maury
jerry springer or somebody because
i would really love to
you know
for my daughter to understand what
really happened and to know that she
said mart what her mom would never do
anything like what y'all oh my god okay
that's
oh my goodness what are we
oh stop sharing okay
what up guys
right flynn
she doubled down the audacity
yo she said call jerry call maury
like
what in the actual world
you don't want to talk to your daughter
you want fame girlfriend that's what she
wants she wants to double down in her
fame and that getting the numbers up
what is wrong with you
go to your daughter's house and have a
conversation with her like you don't
need freaking jerry springer
okay
this is this is why this is why this is
so stupid like you think you need to go
on these like judge judy like jerry
springer shows you're gonna get more
attention and that's all you want you
want all this clout so that you can like
make some money off of it
well didn't you guys always think that
the people that went on jerry springer
and maury were a little bit off like
especially the women that were like
running and screaming like you are not
the father like
that was the real audacity of the 90s
that you would go on a show and you're
like well i mean it's 50 50 shots it's
like him or this other dude but you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna try it i'm
gonna come out on top and the women
and the women that would come back five
times you just be like
come on
like i don't care how much how much you
get paid you can't get paid that much
just like and your reputation is ruined
forever
i i had a family member go on a reality
show once it was not good
what did it what happened
well so he was a
he was an actor
and he pretended to be gay and we were
all like bruh like what
like
but at least you find out that it's
scripted you know what i mean
i just can't believe this woman she's
gaslighting the internet the whole
internet not only did you gaslight your
daughter you guess what me the audacity
i just i just can't get with the nails
and the the
smudged eyeliner
like you want us to feel bad for you
you're you mean to tell me that you got
in the bed
and he like slipped in the bed and you
didn't see each other you didn't know
that you fell in
yeah like he
what is wrong with you you obviously
knew he busted the cheeks for sure or at
least tried i don't know but
oh my gosh like to think that
to think that like if my mom ever did
that oh my gosh that was that's
disgusting like literally this girl
should never speak to both of these
people like
cut them off for good it's just insane
that we're that we live in this world
you know i know the manosphere that says
cheating is different for men and for
women and you know
i i agree to some level
but then they're screwing your girl's
mom
i don't know what i don't know what the
line is
but i think he crossed it
anybody in the chat you ever hooked up
with a girl's family member like her mom
her auntie her grandma be honest be
honest don't lie
any dude did that he'd be literally dead
to me oh my god if i even heard that he
like
attempted with any of my relatives dead
dead to me
there was this one woman um she i think
she posted a tick tock about it she was
in her like mansion in the kitchen and
she was like oh um
i ins i
dumped my boyfriend and got with his dad
and now i have an awesome stepson
oh yeah that's a whole tick tock premise
she's like this this young um
like like african dark woman like
gorgeous and
then she's like married to this old
white guy and she's just like her whole
tick tock page is just crapping on her
stepson
[Music]
and i i want i want to know if it's real
like the husband's real like i've seen
him but i haven't seen like the stepson
but i also think that there's women out
there that have done it like oh 100
100
that is a real thing
that is definitely a real thing
do you know what
someone put but but she told her
daughter that she wasn't treating the
baby daddy right in the original video
hmm
look at i don't know what the line is
but you could tell your daughter you're
not treating your boyfriend right and
not screw him
yeah and if you weren't actually
screwing him you wouldn't say things
like that in the middle of like the
argument you would have just been like
oh like he got in the bed that's so
weird yadda yadda right
you wouldn't like overreact
if it was just oh he just was in the bed
like i didn't know he was here i was
sleeping whatever
but no obviously she was caught
in a lie so she doubled down and was
like now i gotta give her advice because
she's attacking me so i gotta attack
back
i don't know make it like like you
really just should never be alone in a
in a bedroom with like
your daughter's man you know what i mean
like why would you even be in the same
room like you know maybe maybe like
there's there's baby in the room y'all
are like you know bantering whatever but
for the most part like why y'all in a
bedroom together like hang out in the
living room
like normal people
i
pass no way especially especially
because she said like if we're listening
to what she's saying right because she
already put the daughter down she
already put the the earth she put the um
her
grandbaby down so she already put the
baby down right and so
now you don't have an excuse to come to
the bedroom you could have easily gone
to the living room to have a full
conversation with the baby daddy okay
so
she's lying
okay i want to tell you guys what i did
this week
yay
so
as you guys know i i'll be doing these
street interviews
and today i i held up a sign you know
what
i'm in shorts but i'm going to show you
guys the sign because it's right here
hold on hold on okay
no
you didn't the audacity of this [ __ ]
pearl you are trying to get
messed up aren't you like this is what
you're trying to do right
we're like actively concerned for her
safety
we're concerned for your safety like you
are no longer safe because these
feminists will cast spells on you like
they're all witches you didn't know that
are they because i had a couple like
tell me if they're gonna do witchcraft
on me this is like a feminist thing a
lot yes they do the people in the pagan
stuff right
the witchcraft stuff is like the number
one um
religion that's popping up with
feminists and like the
lgbtqia plus minus sign divided by like
all that stuff
the alphabet crew
that's their number one that in satanism
so like you combine the two it's like
you're gonna pearl i'm really concerned
for you should probably hire like body
cards at this point because if you're
gonna be like a steven crowder out there
like you can't
be by yourself okay okay so let's let's
let's talk about these claims
one i don't believe in witchcraft so
they can't witchcraft me if i don't
believe in it facts facts so go ahead
witchcraft me i don't know what that
means like
oh
second off i did hire a bodyguard this
time
good i did i did hire about it was some
random guy off of instagram so hopefully
that goes well
peterson of you perfect
they said
well peter i didn't know i didn't know
where to find a bodyguard someone just
messaged me was like i'm a bodyguard i'm
like okay
you know 18 body fat what is it like six
foot two no we'll we'll do six but right
now
look at he he was doing good he was
doing good
no no i meant like why get a bodyguard
when he could just get a man
i like the way you think yeah slide into
my dms yeah be her bodyguard and hiding
she's gonna hidey cloom that okay
no okay so i was out i was out with that
that sign right had my bodyguard had my
cameraman came too so i wasn't like by
myself right
and this man comes up
and i always said i said abortion is a
cop-out and he's like well what about in
the cases of grape i'm like
we're talking about we're talking about
the rule not exceptions
and this man kept arguing with me he's
like 98 condoms are 98 effective that's
two percent your rule is less than one
percent and he keeps going back and
forth with me and i'm just like okay
sir sir and he kept he kept interrupting
me i'm like sir sir this is my platform
i can argue what i want to argue
if you want to go argue you're two
percent you can go build your own
channel like
i'm gonna have to talk to the next
person but i'm like the audacity these
people come and i'm like i should you
should pay me to argue with you that's
how i feel about it
and i'm like they come up to me and they
have the audacity of telling me what i
need to talk about on my show
yeah
go make your own show
that's what i've been saying that's what
i've been saying on tik tok so now i'm
like trying this my hand at tick tock
for some reason i don't know why
um but
they get mad at me for speaking on my
own platform i'm like if you are that
upset about it all you got to do is
scroll up that's all you got to do right
or just walk away from the conversation
but no they want to literally like they
get so upset
and they're the ones that are making
them upset you didn't do anything
they're getting all up in arms because
like god forbid you have a different
opinion than them and
like
you want to share that on your platform
which you're paying for
you paid for the bodyguard you paid for
the camera man you are sponsoring the
show if they want to do it then they can
pay you to be on the show just like
everyone else does when they like try to
go on these uh celebrity tv shows
like
shut up if you don't if you
okay if
if you are upset about it just
walk away it's really simple it's not
that difficult and i think we've lost
that as a society um
so that's my
that's my two cents on that well i feel
bad for saying this right but people are
doing this vr stuff right
and
like women of all ages are getting
virtually graped and i'm just like
take it off your dang head like just
throw it like what come on
come on
and everything and i'm so sorry but okay
i'm just gonna say this
not everything is grape
if you if you literally
slept with someone and then you felt bad
about it that doesn't mean that i was
great and so i just need to say that for
the women because
y'all are saying that everything is
great
and if it was why didn't you report it
to the cops and why didn't you go to the
hospital and why didn't you get the pill
so that you could take care of that
possible
um i don't know if i can say the a word
on here but why don't you do that no
because you actually are just
dealing with the emotions of the fact
that you didn't want to sleep with that
person and then you consented to it
because you were drunk and they were
drunk and then now y'all got to deal
with it so no not everything is great
not everything is essay and you need to
just understand that
maybe you made a bad decision and maybe
you got to deal with it
and okay if i get drunk and i rob a
store did i not rob the store
did you not drink and drive right you
got in the car you drank and drive you
got in the car you got the dui
so like that's the same thing
you can't you can't blame it on the fact
that you were drunk
like oh my gosh
have you noticed that women have an
excuse for everything so when i'm here i
have this sign i have this sign right
and i'm like i'm going around i'm saying
look i think abortion's a cop-out in
most cases outside of grape i think
abortions cop out because it's and they
said they say why right and i say
because you're you're asking you're
bailing being bailed out for your poor
decisions
and they'll always argue with me they'll
be like well was it a poor decision i'm
like was it a good decision
[Music]
the arguments end really quickly
whenever pearl's like
why are you sleeping with men that you
don't think would be a good father like
that's right it gets posed they're like
you know what
checkmate man check me
or hear me out
and they'll be like well
my body's bad on birth control we'll get
an iud
well i mean we're in cycle tracking i
don't know abstinence i don't
no no there's there's there's weight i
don't want it to be perfect like what do
you mean you want to be relieved of the
burden of giving birth and what you
think like you're just not you're not
going to feel funky at all
like it's a medication like you i like
you gotta deal with it i get it it gives
you mood swings you feel like crap okay
but you don't you want to have
unprotected sex without getting pregnant
like
or get married
yeah or they want to have multiple sex
partners in a month and then they forget
who they actually had sex with on that
day if you are having that many sexual
partners write it down on the calendar
like oh i had sex on this day maybe i
should uh pee on my ovulation stick and
see if i'm ovulating that day if you are
that concerned
but that's the thing is that no one
actually so i've been having this
argument on tick tock because
learning about your body is apparently
not my body my choice apparently
learning about your body is like
so difficult like god forbid you have to
pee on a stick every day which costs
16.59 on amazon to buy a pack of 50 pee
on the stick track your ovulation with a
nap
if you don't want to take birth control
right or get an iud or don't obse or
abstain from sex or try condoms in the
pull-out method like there are so many
there are so many methods of not getting
pregnant right and then they say to the
guys
right they say well if he didn't want to
deal with it he shouldn't he should he
should manage his sperm well you should
close your legs it's the same argument
so i don't get what the actual issue
here is if you don't want to have a baby
like if you never want to have a baby go
get a hysterectomy that will be a full
like you will never have a baby after
that
oh yeah do it if that's what you want
right yeah i mean we told men all the
time to get uh to get vasectomies so
here i have a question for you too okay
because i think like this is mad weird
so
like there's the whole you know
progressive women that if you have a
miscarriage they're like oh like i'm
sorry for your loss but then
if a woman terminates the pregnancy
they're like oh like that was her choice
right so what about mothers
that because this is a real thing that
happened in real life i i found out that
um someone someone uh
i don't know basically sent me a message
about this so they said that the woman
had gotten two determinations of
pregnancies had miscarried twice and
then kept the fifth fifth baby right the
fifth pregnancy but it's like you'll see
with these people
they'll be like oh like i love being a
mom it's the best job in the world look
at my baby and you're like what about
what about like the the other two like i
don't think women that terminate are
like as maternal of women as other women
like it it's it should i don't know like
i just have to get your guys's thoughts
because it's weird to me like how are
you going to convince me that you love
your baby but it's like you love your
baby when it's convenient like they i
think they're kind of nuts you know
that's exactly what it is it's only a
baby when the woman wants the pregnancy
if she doesn't want the pregnancy it's a
clump of cells
if you ask if you literally that's what
it is i go it's a feet like sure it's a
fetus a fetus is a unborn
human baby
still a baby
it's gonna grow
and come out be a perfectly healthy baby
so
if you don't do anything like if you
don't do anything medically the baby's
going to grow you're going to survive
and everyone's going to be okay right
but
they want to take dangerous pills they
want to do like the the hanger method
and all this other stuff to their bodies
cool do that and then you'll never have
a baby you'll never get to the point
like if you finally get to the point
where okay i'm finally get got out of my
delusion and now i want a baby well you
messed up all of that stuff because you
took too many abortion pills um you got
to do it a dnc scrape too many times and
guess what
your uterus has too much scarring and
you can't hold
the it can't hold a pregnancy so
i'm so sorry but um
that's how biology works so
these people that are saying um it's not
a it's a clump of cells it's this that
okay
um go to princeton.edu
and look up when conception uh
conception starts right look up
justfax.org
the medical community the scientific
community
pretty much affirms that life begins
at freaking conception okay sorry i'm
rebecca i have a question i'm a mom and
i'm a mom so this triggers me more than
anything rebecca i have a question i
don't people always ask me if i think
the plan b is a form of abortion and i
don't have a good answer because
i i looked it up and it says it's not
but they said can so i'm like i don't
know so plan b is basically all of the
birth control that you take in a month
condensed into one pill or two pills
however it is
so
it's basically like the
the
biggest birth control pill that you
could take
that's what you're like that's what
you're taking you're taking like
basically all the doses in a month in
one take i don't know if they still make
two pills or one pill but
it's
basically that
so what did it yes they could
oh god
you could say that it is an abortion
because you're triggering your period
sorry guys you're gonna hear about
periods um
period to come but also if you take like
actual um like herbs you can also
induce your period to come too which a
lot of people don't know that
interesting i just i always get asked
that question and i'm like i don't
actually know
when i'm out with my sign
well that's what i've been told it's
basically
it's basically um
the condensed version of
all of your birth control in one month
oh wow does that sound good also
freely accessible ladies i was in the
united states army they gave you two
plan b's a year for free okay it's like
fifty dollars
all right go get you one if it's really
that important crazy thing is hearing
stories of babies that are like they're
like this baby survived two plan b's i'm
like
oh
also
also if you like if you're underage
because that's like where they're
telling people like they're telling
women oh like what happens if you're
underage if you're underage and you can
drink alcohol like you
you find ways to
get alcohol and cigarettes
i think you could probably
finagle
getting a plan b
okay i'm just saying if you can if you
can coerce people to get you alcohol you
can coerce someone to go get you a plan
b girlfriend you don't need to go to the
abortion clinic and here's the other
thing too if you're tracking your period
right if you're tracking your cycle
every month
and you have to you happen to have sex
um in that time right
you can go early where like the the
six week some of the states have like
the harpy bill you can go
do whatever you need to do
right because you found out early
because you were tracking your cycle and
because you were writing it down and you
know
how many people you had sex with that
month like
that's more control
over your body than just saying well
we're just going to leave it up to
chance we'll figure it out
you want to go
40 of women that have had abortions have
had two or more
yeah and and that and you don't know out
of the 60
what what percentage of them are gonna
get it in the future so it just seems to
this is what i would tell people on the
street i'm like it just seems to be like
a
cop out
for poor decisions
anyways ally go on oh yeah yeah so like
i have an extraordinarily long cycle
like uh i mean for most people it's like
35 to 39 days so like but but even so
like you can track it in like
like six weeks you know you if you're a
woman
who like you get um you menstruate like
every two months or something like you
you would know right which you would
probably just have to take pregnancy
tests routinely if you're having
unprotected sex but i think it was like
six weeks go by and you're not like you
know
kind of weird i just i haven't i haven't
bled like what what do you mean like it
goes over your head like you just forgot
like
you're just not gonna ask like how how
many drugs are you doing like how many
how hard are you partying where you're
like it just never came i don't know
that's that's honestly like what i ask
all the time like how do you not know
how do you not know even if you have an
irregular cycle also if you have an
irregular cycle go get that check that's
probably a hormonal issue that you
probably need more
work to figure out where why that is
because
most women should have normal cycles 24
or 28 day cycles
um so
figure it out
stop pre like stop let's stop
normalizing irregular cycles how about
that right there you go
well and now they're putting
how do you guys feel about sex ed in
schools because i'm very anti-sex ed
because this is just my opinion
i think that that's your conversation
your parents should have with you um and
then the argument will always be well
what if you don't have the best parents
well i think
you know with
that we can encourage better parents
without teaching kid cause to me it's
like teaching kids how to have sex my 15
year old child doesn't need to be taught
how to have sex
i was very innocent when i was a kid
okay i i remember i was 15 and someone
said the hand job and i didn't know what
that was i was like yeah i was like
what's a [ __ ]
i don't youtube don't don't don't
oh my god there's a mosquito but okay
anyways um
but but i'm like and that that gives old
men and women power to be predatory
because like if you're gonna test the
waters with a child what are you gonna
do with
that's like the that's like a job for a
groomer
so what do you guys think it doesn't
work
like the stats don't show that like sex
education is really all that effective
like we we had
like mad pregnant chicks in my high
school like what what are you even i'm
done and i do think it gives children
ideas right because you don't know
things until you're taught them
there's like lots of circumstances where
i'm like oh well i heard that in school
so surely you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
see about that like myself and it's like
you're not necessarily smart enough or
old enough to be making those kinds of
decisions so i would agree with you and
then they tell you about like your your
rights and like how to get birth control
and like how to go behind your parents
back basically and it's pretty bad so um
those of you that are watching
scarlet teen is a resource that schools
are pushing to kids that are you know
trying to get like sexual education
it's a scary af website like what
they're pushing to kids it's a
non-profit
and
let's pull it up oh it's it's groomy af
roomy af let's see scarlett i found it
let me share i just want to see
share screen okay
just
oh
whoa there's a section called
there's a what there's a segment in the
top right called quickies
quickies what the f where
the top
yeah
oh my god wait quickies
how to make new relationships and new
people to pause and have sex more safely
during the pandemic
[Music]
my god quickies masturbation oh it's
like the quick definition of what it is
that's what it is it's still pretty
groomy
oh
here here's the thing here's where i
have like the issue with like sex ed in
school right
when it's not based in biology now
they're
they're trying to do all these gender
studies right and so they're telling
girls that they can become
guys and guys that can come girls and if
you want to be non-binary and be a tree
you can be a tree if you want like you
can identify as a cat and pee in a
litter box in the bathroom like
that's what
like that's what the gender that's what
sex said is in school and it is very
groomy and so i think it's very
important that parents
like
teach their children about this at the
proper age right not the birds and the
bees blah blah but like literally based
in biology like
this is what this is this is what that
part is right not
like this is how you masturbate really
quickly um so you don't i don't know so
you don't get blue balls like i don't
know
because i don't know what these people
are teaching in the schools i just know
i just know that what they're teaching
in the schools is that like kids are
coming out more and more and more
confused like
that whole tran like
the trans um
ideology there's more trans kids i
p kids that identify as trans i think
it's like up 40 or something i don't
know the stat maybe one of you could
pull it up um and then they're also
and they're also targeting
um
kids with autism and kids that uh you
know on the neurodivergent spectrum and
so it's very predatory it's not you know
it's
i don't know there's no biology in it
if we if we actually learn biology in
biology class we would learn about these
things but they don't they just want to
push
uh these gender studies where you can be
a you can identify as a tree a nut
freaking plant
i wanna i wanna identify as will smith
so i can leave jada
right
like i want to identify as everything
like i can identify as whatever like you
have to believe me
right i want to identify as a 10.
that's what
i've learned to love myself so i'm a 10
now guys give me my free oil change give
me give me yeah yeah me too actually i
changed it
oh my gosh heidi's crumbling
okay well who wants to host next week
i know rebecca you should we come to
your channel
we have nothing returned there's there's
nothing happening on my channel yeah
that said it could this could be on your
channel next week perfect perfect
so yeah we'll have to be at this time my
time pearl is literally it's like two
o'clock in the morning her time because
she's crazy and she's like she's up
till five o'clock i don't know
um but yeah we could do it back out
rebecca calm down
3 30 is typically what i go to
oh my god girl that can't be healthy
well i do a night show like it keeps me
up
do you sleep during the day
yeah i wake up at like noon every day oh
you're like a hooker
i'm sorry you're on that crackhead
schedule yeah you're on the prostitute
schedule what do you think i did
i'm not sure i passed my classes this
semester
you're still going to school like i
thought you just dropped out of school
and started
starting no because it made you more
money than going to school no no i've
been in school i just have been like
failing
so yeah like i haven't been doing school
well but i've been doing it so 166 000
subs over a bachelor's degree like i
just got i got my degree in the old
masters but i got my degree in the mail
and i'm like looking at it like
what the hell like why did i
like i'm not gonna do anything with it
i'm just staring at it like
what i don't that's my problem i don't
care like i just don't but i'm like i
need it for my visa so i gotta finish oh
my god
fine
boo hoo
first world problems
i know i know okay well so next week
we're doing this on rebecca's channel
for a time
stay tuned we'll do it after one of my
shows wait actually
it's gotta be tuesday or wednesday
because after that i'm going out of town
what do you want to do wednesday
yeah we can do wednesday all right
wednesday
do i have to do like the the welcome to
the show
no you can do your own
that's my intro that i do on my channel
if you like it then you can
you can take it i don't i don't own
clapping so
i do i do let others do that if you um
oh that's good that's great thanks for
let for sharing in the cloud okay i got
you check this out let me turn it down
though
there you go ally ally with this down
board like you just need to
you need a sound board for us like but
you got it what is rebecca's thing it
just boggles my mind that or make it
make sense um
what else oh i like that make it make
sense i go like jesus like i don't know
just
chop whatever baby girl oh yeah i
love i love baby girl yeah i'm like
leave the whales
[Laughter]
oh my god actually i have one more story
before we add this girl came on my show
this week and there and then she she was
bigger but she says to my recruiter
she's like
does pearl know i'm fat
oh
and i'm like i'm like i don't hate fat
people i don't like it when they're
entitled
that's what i don't like oh yeah
women are the best like they make the
best pies you know look at it
i got i got no beef what i got beef with
is a girl selling themselves at 120 and
then getting 100 pounds before they got
kids and then saying love me that's
that's my issue
pearl i have a question for you do you
um
like the people that go viral
in your show
right do they get mad at you and do you
like i don't know if you're gonna if i'm
gonna blow up your stuff right now but
do you make them sign like the waivers
and stuff like
everyone else so that you can use their
um some people well they have um consent
like by coming on the show you're
consenting to come on facts so like they
don't really have a leg to stand on i
did get threatened to get sued once um i
said okay do it she never did
um shocked and
um and then
what kind of thing yeah like some
there's one girl that called me and was
mad but i was just like
because i i clipped her and i said
like women love bad boys and they
complain technically i didn't even clip
her it was i i have two guys that like
do it for me and so
um
and then i was like
what was incorrect about the clip you
dated a bad boy and now you're
complaining on my show oh
yeah and i was just like
yeah and then some people i hand them a
golden damn ticket because i know
but they don't they get so in their
feelings there's one in particular that
they may have said in the comments that
i i she could have been on every red
pill show and made thousands of dollars
off of because she was so entertaining
so i would say incorrect i would say she
was she was not making sense but if
you're entertaining enough no one cares
look at what happened to that girl that
said her ex is paying her bills she got
a whole podcast off of that
that is true her it doesn't matter if
they love you or hate you but it's just
like i give people a golden ticket
oh yeah
yeah so some some like ally capitalize
they make businesses
others usually the liberals call me and
complain just like they complain about
the bad boys
well you know like you're actually
empowering women like they talk about
like empowered women empower women but
it's always like some broad working at
like a like a lash business that's like
struggling you know like pearl out here
actually doing it though rebecca too you
guys both helped me so look at that look
at that look at the anti-feminists
helping each other out you know maybe
we'll take over actually maybe maybe
perhaps
i don't know we probably
i don't know
they hate us they hate us too much they
hate us because they ain't us
because we're pick me's apparently and
we would like god forbid i
speak facts to women and they're just
pissed off all the time that's okay
though i'm totally fine with it the
thing is that like to to do this to be
completely honest you have to have some
level of like
like
oh what's it called
kind of like
what is that stuff like the skin thing
what is it sorry my brain is thick skin
god my brain doesn't function at guys
i'm on a sleep regression my daughter's
not sleeping through the night um
and you have to be like a duck where
like just all this stuff kind of comes
off of you so it is like it sucks you
know it is hard sometimes but it's fun
it's really fun and it's kind of fun to
troll it's kind of fun to troll on tick
tock that's something that i was telling
my husband today how easy you can take a
candy from a baby
and you're like well that only works if
you make him wear one stupid
if you're just staring at it it doesn't
work like that's not how it works like
well in my mind i asked him
you know i thought he would just know
that i wanted him to wear one i didn't
think he like come on what is it uh
sarah says uh you're the head of
security of your womb i love that i love
that why
that is amazing that is amazing
bruh
it's like i don't understand why billy
has ever excused in the book except you
know what i made a poor decision
i just don't i'm a big believer and
everything that happens to you is your
own goddamn fault i've been in bad
relationships and it was my own fault
like how am i how am i gonna complain
about someone i picked yeah do you guys
remember when i called into kevin
samuel's show like that was like really
embarrassing it was like the word y'all
oh
no no no
that was a bad
look but you know i overcame it turned
out all right it actually turned out to
be a good things
but you know you just take
accountability because people that go
viral for the wrong reasons with pearl
they'd be like you used me i'm like
but you showed up though in front of the
camera the internet's forever come on
you gotta learn something well i knew
you could look up my channel
why didn't you look at it like and i i
didn't make you there's hundreds of
people that have come on my show and
haven't gone viral
i don't make you say anything
yo the the people that are saying like
oh you forced women to do this you force
i didn't force anyone to do anything you
open your legs
voluntarily okay that was not me that
was not me that did that you did that
girlfriend so you gotta own
those decisions you gotta own the
consequences of that okay it's like
anything no you went on the show because
you wanted to get some internet fame you
got it capitalize on it and maybe you
make something of yourself
but
just complaining about it is not going
to get you anywhere
or you can go on jerry springer or maury
or all right i'd rather go on i'd rather
go on pearl's show i think it sounds
like fun we got to get pearl over to the
states guys draw some super chats
there's been a couple yeah people people
have been saying hi so yeah
swedish thank you let me see talk about
the feminist attorney interview i
haven't seen that
um i'll see if there's any other super
chat
to be honest
really why would i say that again
a lot of attorneys are feminists i don't
know why
pearl why are you so passionate about
the red pill stuff and why are you in
the uk i'm in the uk for volleyball
i'm passionate about red pill um i
wouldn't even i'd say i'm more
passionate about conservative values and
so a lot of those align with red pill
um
every guy is trying to protect pearl and
alley goes to show
how much men miss normal women hashtag
bodyguard yeah any bodyguards in the uk
tammy on instagram i might respond
if you want to get hired
five dollar super sticker
yeah
if a pregnant woman gets hit in the gut
causing her to lose a child is that
murder or is it only what the woman if
the woman wants the baby i mean make it
make sense
my catch phrase is choices begin before
you drop your knickers not after a
positive
pregnancy test
um
hecate keep up the good work
i think that's
everything
yay thanks guys thank you for the
vacation
look at that ali is the best ally's the
best live streamer
yo i suck at it that's why i'm like
should i host you guys on my show
because i don't know what to do anymore
i literally am the worst youtuber on
this planet we got your back we're used
to it oh the feminist interview with
pearl outside oh i did interview a
lawyer and she was a feminist and
yeah she that's a whole i'll send you
guys a video maybe next week well yeah
the audacity of this [ __ ]
let's do that let's play that one for
next week it's audacity
where we got more super chats oh someone
said can you do a show on cheating
i mean yeah i'm happy to do that you
want cheating that's fine just like why
would you say no that's stupid it's like
you're asking your man to cheat i saw
like the finest husband ever in target
today
his wife
she i don't know what happened but i'm
like man you were not trying like you
were not mate guarding
wait wait i have a video for next week
y'all are gonna die it's i saved i saved
it and it's
it's about that like it's about like a
hot husband and a
i mean she's all right
yeah good enough right like i'm like i
don't want you taken by the secretary
i'm sorry
well they went viral because they posted
a picture
of them in their like bikinis or like
swimsuits and it was you didn't expect
what was like going on there like you
didn't expect them to be together you
thought they were brother and sister and
so it just yeah
i think i know who a couple you're
talking about oh sentience sentience
like my number one donator he is yes
ladies please stop encouraging women to
improve we men are thankful to have a
permanent record of who to avoid in the
future and what pitfalls to evolve
find out in one's court my friend it's
like they turned like it's like
definitely just like they peel their
face back they're like i was crazy the
whole time
okay guys tell the people where they can
find you
all right go ally
you can find me at real fam sapien on
youtube and instagram and on tick tock
something happened with the algorithm on
tick tock so help you girl out click on
some stuff over there and you know just
remember we will always have the
audacity for the women who also had the
audacity the audacity of this [ __ ]
okay
um you can find me
at my youtube channel
rebecca barrett really simple my name's
right there um and on instagram and tick
tock at
i am rebecca barrett um
so
that's where you can find me
oh we got one more super chat one more
um i think fresh and fit trying to say
it's okay for a man to cheat is not
conducive to the life but men and women
is not conducive to returning to the
life men and women had in the 1900s yeah
red pill isn't necessarily conservative
i always say that that's kind of where i
fit in is i do i like conservative and
red pill
so
anyways guys like the video on your way
out we had so much fun today talking
[ __ ]
so i should talk for the week if you
want to see us next week wednesday same
time on rebecca's channel so you better
go subscribe so you'll see me live there
too
anyways i'll talk to you guys next time
peace out
bye